four weeks ago 227 people were getting
ready to leave Kuala Lumpur over the
next 24 hours some would say goodbye to
their families others would look forward
to saying hello again to there's some
were here in Asia on business some were
on holiday the other 12 were Malaysia
Airlines crew flying around the world
was their job in 24 hours they'd be
getting ready for just another shift at
work it was anything but
Kuala Lumpur Malaysia
a city content to quietly thrive as its
continental neighbors Singapore Hong
Kong Shanghai Hulk the limelight
for 27 days this aspirational city has
been the reluctant center of the world
Malaysia like many Asian Nations is a
proud country but that can make it seem
sometimes as though it's scared to admit
its own mistakes well this past month in
full view of the world it has had to
grow up its government has been
scrutinized and questioned by outsiders
but also by its own people they have
been judged not as usual by their own
standards that by everybody else's
there's too much in competence for it to
be in competence if that makes any sense
you know I honestly believe that there
is active deception going on I'm just
not clear at times the Malaysian people
haven't known who to believe the
conspiracy theorists or the clear
thinking realists the critical foreign
media or the tame domestic press
national corporations have bought
advertising space on Billboard's
alongside the highways into town food
for thought on the morning rush out
shoppers continue to hang their tags of
sympathy outside the city swanky malls a
temporary pause for reflection before
resuming their march towards the
boulevards of designer boutiques having
done their bit of course what none of
them say is the one thing that has gone
through everybody's mind this was a
routine flight on a respected
international airline who hasn't thought
I'm just glad it wasn't me for almost
four weeks now the families of the 239
people on board flight mh370 have waited
longingly for news mostly from hotel
rooms in Beijing or Kuala Lumpur paid
for by Malaysian Airlines instead of
returning to the painful familiarities
of the homes they shared with the now
missing these have been bubbles of hoop
and desperation purgatory on planet
Earth sometimes a haven from the prying
eyes of the media at other times mccobb
theaters of inconsolable grief most days
the relatives were briefed by officials
from either the airline or from the
Malaysian government as to the latest in
the investigation we in the media and
there were thousands gathered here in
the first few weeks would have to wait
until later in the afternoon often for
the daily press conference the relatives
would also be watching that live
streamed into their hotel it was the
first time that we would find out about
the latest it was often as well the
first time the families would find out
about the latest in the investigation
that night the Prime Minister came here
for a hastily arranged press conference
and told the world that inmarsat the
British satellite company had tracked
the plane into the southern Indian Ocean
it was a shock to us but for the
relatives watching in their hotel it was
the first time they had heard that
tragic news as well and some of these
are people who who I've worked with in
the past
some have kept their counsel choosing to
endure the past month in private others
have found comfort in the arms of
strangers the reassuring messages of
support or condolence posted on Twitter
Facebook Weibo and the like many have
willingly expose themselves to the very
naked experience of television
interviews allowing us to watch their
heartache in full HD I do not believe
the plane has crashed I have yet to find
any expert who have I've talked to that
off record has said that they believe
the plane has crashed everybody believes
it's been taken by believing Philip
might still be alive somewhere you
potentially opening yourself in a
position where the worst is yet to come
that could be but I don't even consider
it a question I absolutely believe he's
still alive I still feel his presence I
am NOT a metaphysical weirdo I'm a very
grounded practical logical thinking
person but I still feel him in the same
way I have always felt him that has not
changed
for some the media attention will have
been an unforgiving experience nothing
but a rude intrusion into a
life-changing turn of events that you
would wish on no one each relative has
their own reasons for wanting to give
interviews to the media some have told
me they just simply find it therapeutic
others want to tell the world about how
great their loved one is how much they
miss them and then of course there's a
group who use the media as a microphone
to amplify their anger their sheer
frustration but for weeks on nothing has
been found yet a group of Chinese
relatives have done that with great
effect they don't represent the majority
let's be clear about that but no one can
deny them their emotions in such a
situation anger and grief are never far
apart the Malaysian government has had
to listen and act like it or not
consistently into the pen remember my
only problem is giving them aye sir to
the question that
no which is where we loved ones in the
image 27 daughters they have marched on
the malaysian embassy in beijing such a
protest in the Chinese capital he's
almost unheard of and eventually fed up
of not getting the answers they want
they flew to kuala lumpur in search of
the truth we traveled with them the main
purpose of our journey is to demand
evidence and truth for loved ones we are
here to see how it goes step by step
because in Beijing were totally
desperate there's nothing coming out of
Beijing on landing they held another
demonstration one person on board mh370
has been the subject of attention more
than any other and most of that
attention has been suspicion that person
of course is the Hari ahmed shah the
planes captain did he bring it down was
his marriage in trouble could that have
been a motive friends have rushed to his
defense painting a profile of a
professional man who loved his job and
loved his family they were very loving
family man going through some troubles
it's been reported I don't think so
because I I've seen photos of the family
which was quite reason when I'm sick in
a middle last year well twas the sep
tember or so they look like a typical
happily married couple with a good
family a grandson here's a grandson
there's been a lot of rumor that he had
very strong political beliefs that his
marriage was breaking down that maybe he
had extreme religious views any of that
true in your opinion don't believe in
rumors to me he's innocent until proven
guilty and it's not around the defense
that how about a possible political
connection was captain zaharie a radical
it has been a theory that has done the
rounds he is a supporter of the
opposition party in Malaysia he knew
well the controversial opposition leader
who told me that the government played
up their connection in a politically
motivated Act of skullduggery we have
called for a parliamentary select
committee to be formed immediately
because from our point of view the
Malaysian in the intern mhm in terms of
image has been just devasted I think the
Melissa guy may need to learn that they
have to be more transparent to their
friends and family that 239 missing are
real people and their characters have
been lost along with them to the
investigators though they are just 239
random names whose backgrounds need to
be checked out why were they flying to
Beijing did they have any motive to
bring down the plane or to hijack it but
the Royal Malaysian police has announced
that none of the passengers are under
investigation anymore the crew remained
suspects though 239 people missing 14
different nationalities six of them
Australians from the country
coordinating the search effort the
Malaysian Prime Minister Najib Razak has
flown to Perth to meet his counterpart
Tony Abbott and the air crews flying
grueling daily missions I know that
until we find a plane many families
cannot start to grieve I cannot imagine
what they must be going through but I
can promise them that we will not give
up for the first time in the
investigation the tone is changing to
downplay expectations all the search
teams need is one stroke of luck
the disappearance of mh370 continues to
fascinate and whatever the conclusion of
this extraordinary mystery if indeed
there is one the 239 missing will live
long in the memories of many
eventually maybe there will be a need
for something more permanent to remember
them by
malaysia puts its history on full view
whether it be bad or good mh370 is
already a part of that but all in time
because for now whilst the plane might
still be missing all is not lost
Alastair buncle Sky News Kuala Lumpur